hello there
according to leakers and data miners
season 5 of battle royale
will once again have an end of season
event i personally did not expect that
so i guess now's the time to get hyped
unlike chapter one we've only had two
end of season events
in chapter two the time midas found the
zero point and made a plasma ball rave
party
and more recently tony stark let us
drive the battle bus
and galactus hit me so hard he slapped
the guitar off my back
happy memories season five has brought
us a ton of lore to go through
which has given us a host of possible
events and themes for season six
but which of these will happen here's
seven theories that look increasingly
possible
oh i forgot to say sit your butt down
for 10 minutes and think about slapping
code adamarro in the store to support my
nonsense
okay let's go
[Music]
let's start with the most common story
theory most people believe will happen
at the end of this season and the start
of the next
the full reveal of io and the unveiling
of their leader
this theory has gained momentum mainly
because of one skin in particular
the anticipated female variant of the
midas skin
let's set the scene season 5 has been
focused around
agent jonesy jon jones reclaiming the
loop by any means necessary
hunting down deviant snapshots who are
trying to escape
that rift globe he carries may be able
to rip the fabric of time
allowing jonesy to recruit hunters from
any dimension
but little does he realize all his
shenanigans are causing the zero point
to destabilize
his memory must be short because we all
remember what went down in season x
season x is here and the world is
destabilizing
fast johnsy is making mistakes and needs
help
before the zero point is pushed too far
which leads to many people believing
jonesy's boss will be revealed in the
live event and she will jump into the
loop
to put right his wrongs we've looked at
who i think the idol boss is
ramirez but some people suggest it could
be singularity from season 9
or the much anticipated female variant
of the midas skin let's go a little
further down this rabbit hole
season 2 ended with agent jones's reveal
and season 5
kicked off with a glimpse back into the
world of jon jones and the imagined
order
it's now three seasons since we heard a
voice for the first time face to face
or should i say an understandable voice
since then jonesy has been around the
multiverse keeping audio logs
the reason i bring voices up is because
we actually know of three members of the
imagined order
we've heard them well actually four if
you count the io troopers but that's a
story for another time
johnsy has been our main focus so far
but think back to season two and the
conversation behind closed doors
between agent jonesy and janice not
stable over here janice janice uh dial
the resonance actuator to 7.2
now he's yes right now i'm on it by
clipping through the wall we could see
janice is the envoy skin but it's their
boss we want to see
identified i made a video recently
explaining that i think it's ramirez
but the coolest story would be to unveil
female midas
as the io leader by doing that it would
explain why the other mida snapshot was
able to pinpoint the zero point
and build a hulking gray agency on top
of it the io leader may have put herself
in the loop just as we've seen johnsy do
many times over the years
therefore that mida snapshot holds the
memories of the isle leader
and thus use them to break the cycle and
return home
by collapsing the loop the twist to this
story is that jonesy is now tasked with
preventing that from happening
and to quote the king of defaults no one
is escaping the loop
no one is escaping the loop not on my
watch
not even his own boss
[Music]
the second theory is my personal
favorite the return of the seven and the
breaking of the zero point
the last time we officially heard from
the seven they successfully ruptured the
nexus
and destroyed the original island in one
of the greatest live events ever seen
we watched the rocket break the
space-time continuum
and drag us into a black hole the days
of waiting for the new season to be
revealed
made that even more impactful before
that the seven finally revealed their
intentions to stop the loop
and escape the same thing midas tried
and the same thing johnsy is tasked with
preventing
we've hoped for the seven to return for
over a year now so why is this season
any different it comes back to that very
first phone call of the season
between the io boss and agent johnsy she
directly tells him
do not draw the attention of the seven
the last thing we need
is someone escaping the loop you need to
get in there and fix it
understood ma'am i'm on it and do not
draw the attention of the seven
jones but the real issue
is that he completely missed this
warning and judging by how he's going a
little overboard in his recruitment
it's highly likely the seven will return
during the event
take a look at the zero point it's
slowly becoming unstable again
and it's all jonesy's fault every time
he uses that
thing hang on what the hell do i call it
is it as shard of the zero point
is it a magic snow globe of reality
whatever it is
each time it's used it ruptures the zero
point further
attracting the attention of others and
most likely causing the zero point to
become
unstable a live event which lets us
experience going inside the zero point
again would be both
a cool end of season extravaganza but it
would also add to the law
which many of us are here for remember
the butterfly event which opened our
eyes to alternative realities
maybe it's time to go back and the seven
will be always watching
but whilst we're saying this remember
why johnsy is here to stabilize the zero
point
and to reseal the bridge which of course
is the place the seven found a weakness
in the loop
and finally his last objective is to not
let anyone escape
i doubt he can master all three of these
i guess we wait and see but i have to
admit the return of the seven seems like
the most likely turn of events
on this list until then i'll be looking
at this tree carving
constantly
three now and something i spoke about a
few months back when the season began
the convergence this theory is that the
island and all the combatants are slowly
realigning
and things are going back to the
original chapter
even agent jonesy who recently arrived
in a new suit
is being dragged back to his old self
when the season began many of us placed
maps on top of maps to confirm the
island
is once again returning to its original
format og locations like the durburger
dusty containers and flush factory
all appeared in the same places we saw
them back in 2019
the convergence suggests that the power
of the zero point is uncontrollable
and nobody can stop what is happening
those in the loop will slowly lose
themselves and snapshots will be brought
back together
agent jones is the person to watch as we
know there's tens if not
hundreds of jonesy snapshots in the loop
from bunker jonesy to the slurp infused
version of jonesy
and i recently remembered that even
peely is a jonesy snapshot
the convergence suggests that all of
those characters are being brought back
together by the zero point
we have to keep watching agent jonesy to
see if this comes true
have you noticed that his attire changes
every time he uses that weapon
his suit begins to fall to pieces and
look at his tie it's now on his arm
again
just like the original johnsy from back
in 2017
coincidence i think not in my opinion
this theory is a little too long-winded
to be the theme of season six
but there's a chance as those seasons
continue that more chapter one content
drops back in
and the convergence will one day happen
right now there is talk that lucky
landing is returning to
yet another og landing spot and that
leads me on to the next theory
the season of the foxclan
[Music]
are you in the fortnite crew i am and my
feelings change about this each month
but the moment v was announced the crew
became unmissable to me
and i'm hoping that's for story reasons
over a few hours the fortnite twitter
account
announced v in a great way allowing her
to hack their twitter
and call for help from drift a character
we haven't seen since chapter one season
five
a californian man who was rifted into
the world of fortnite and a few weeks
later he received this
mask nothing much there right well we
now know the fox clan is being hunted
and by receiving that mask drift is
hunted too
we expected a map update to bring back
the foxclan's poi
lucky landing but as of right now nah
nothing nothing at all
many of us did extra research and linked
the fox gland to a hunter who is already
in the game
condor one of agent jones's original
picks
in the audio log we find out that condor
is an ancient spirit
who is here for vengeance he's also a
genie of sorts who will grant any wish
for revenge and vengeance you may be
thinking what does this have to do with
the fox clan
that comes down to his audio log in
which we are told
he has a thing for cherry blossoms and
the only place we see cherry blossom in
fortnite
is that lucky landing i truly expected
lucky landing to be present at the end
of season five
but as each day goes on it's less and
less likely so maybe
season six or should i say season v
i dun this
nicely leads into our next theory the
inevitable return
of kevin the cube
the story of kevin has kept us all
enthralled for seasons
i remember being in game when he first
arrived
and we all rushed across the map to see
him in person the cube went for a walk
around the map and we all weaponized it
every day the community watched him
unknowing of why he arrived or what he
wanted
that all became apparent when he fell
into loot lake and revealed the vault
which held the zero point and set up
everything we know about the storyline
we currently find ourselves in
since chapter two though we haven't seen
him we were led to believe steamy stacks
was his resting place but
nothing ever happened here but there are
clues
everywhere first have you noticed the
chaos agent skin has been in the shop
more times than usual this season
did you know on the back of his mask are
symbols just like those found on the
cube
this season another character received
kevin the cube style glyphs
take a look at a hunter we've already
looked at in this video
condor his weapon rap once again dons
kevin's runes
this theory doesn't have a great deal
going for it right now but creators keep
adding to this
recently cipher pk said the birthplace
of kevin the cube in the first chapter
map
lines up with the bunker in chapter two
and to go back to our previous theory
about convergence
would kevin reawaken in this spot it
would make sense as there is now a
bunker there keeping it safe
i also lined up the maps to fact-check
this for myself and i found that the
actual spot kevin awakened in chapter
one
is exactly where hot watch stands right
now kevin knocked down the original hut
which i went on to call hot watch and if
you didn't know
during the erection of this big shot
building in chapter two
each update was called hut watch in the
game's code
and wait there's more look who was there
when the cube first arrived
drift from the fox clan all these
theories are now linking up
and although they do remain coincidences
the return of kevin the cube
is inevitable will season six be that
time
[Music]
time for one more theory it isn't a full
theory more of a hint but i think it's
worth a shout out
this is the reboot van key theory
remember when reboot vans appeared in
2019
they were 100 a stolen concept from
fortnite's challenger at the time apex
legends
and epic being epic took this concept
and ran with it
evolving the mechanic along the way
right now in game these bands are
getting attention from the legendary
bunker johnsy he tells us the vans the
bunkers the elevators
it's all tied together it must be
remember this is the guy who knew the
battle between the mech and the monster
would happen in season nine
his foresight is limitless we should
trust him
he tells us i still think those bands
could be our way out of the loop
and goes as far as to ask who owns the
vans
io ghost maybe bigfoot they've got us
trapped
johnsy tells us about midas returning
and not being the same guy he once was
linking midas to reboot cards again and
not trusting the manufacturers
from all the times we've spoken to
bunker johnsy he seems like the most
aware of his situation
and always thinking about ways to escape
if the reboot vans are the way out of
the loop
then johnsy is the gatekeeper here but
which john is he
old man johnsy with a beard as long as
your mums or agent johnsy
and his meddling in the loop maybe the
vans will let us hop between realities
and reboot in other time periods
there's an upcoming ps5 game named
ratchet and clank ripped apart
which allows this kind of travel maybe
the rifts left behind by johnsy
will be the doors needed to escape the
loop so which one of these seven
theories
do you think has the most potential what
will happen in the live event
and what would you like to see in season
six i'm adam from playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time